escribamos 0.36 como una fracción y
bueno hay muchísimas formas de hacer
esto y una de ellas es fijarnos que el
último dígito de aquí o sea este 6 está
en el lugar de las centésimas entonces
esto dice que hay 6 centésimas y por
otro lado este 3 está en el lugar de las
décimas
si tienes 3 décimas partes de algo
entonces en realidad tienes 30
centésimas partes de algo al final todo
se reduce a que hay 36 centésimas y con
eso ya hemos escrito a 0.36 como una
fracción pero lo podemos escribir como
una fracción simplificada aquí estos dos
términos tienen factores comunes el 4
divide a estos dos números así es que
mejor vamos a dividir estos dos números
entre 4 y como estamos dividiendo tanto
el numerador como el denominador entre 4
entonces no se afecta a la fracción
entonces 36 entre 4 a cuánto es igual 9
por 4 es 36 así es que aquí está el 9
100 entre 425 entonces 0.36 se puede
escribir como una fracción escribiendo
simplemente 36 entre 100 y se puede
escribir como una fracción simplificada
donde no hay factores comunes entre el
numerador y el denominador como 925 abós